he commented a skip said it does Burt
drink as much as people think well you
know it you know I've worked with him a
few times the first time I worked with
him was in Lexington Kentucky at comedy
off Broadway and I guess he was sick
and he really didn't drink much at all
he would just drink during the shows and
and then he wouldn't party at all after
and then on the bodyshots tour he
parties hard but during the day he
didn't drink he went for runs and he he
wouldn't drink and then he would
wouldn't drink until the second show of
the night but yeah then it's you know
then it's boss of the wall I mean the
guy after the show I mean it's let loose
and I mean it's fun he never I never
always saw him one time and all the
nights we were together where he seemed
like he got pretty drunk I mean he
handles it well for me a person that
doesn't drink I mean the biggest problem
for me is that Burt would get super
drunk and just want to hang out all
night and I'm up till 4:00 a.m. drinking
coffee just trying to stay awake it'd be
a blast if I still drank but there's
nothing for me to do I'm just hanging
out like still very aware of everything
going on
I've been who stayed out till like 4:00
a.m. or Orleans yeah I mean it's and I'm
walking back to the bus with all of them
like very sober and walking by guys
being like I got that Coke
I got coke and I'm like even if I were
looking for coke right now I don't think
I want it from a guy on the street at
4:00 a.m. in New Orleans yeah I mean I'm
not trying to snort baking soda out here
I bet his fans are crazy too though I
would imagine they go wild they're so
great I mean the best thing about the
tour I mean cuz Birds very nice I like
him a lot but the he would invite we
would do two shows in every city and he
would invite he would tell the club or
tell the people where we were going
after hmm so we would walk into these
bars after the show and it's like we're
like celebrities even me I'm like you
know I mean
I say even me only because I'm not
popular like Bert Kreischer is popular
but it was amazing cuz my shows were
going well so I would walk in and people
were excited to see me and I loved it I
loved being on that tour I mean honestly
I just want Bert to let me go to sleep
like the old man yeah I mean I'm like
really yeah I mean I I like to do my
show and then I go back to my hotel and
hang out for a couple hours I don't mind
popping into a bar for a second but I
don't lie I'm not trying to hang do you
have any favorite words
well the quarantine has honestly not
been bad for me because I like just
hanging out at home if I had more land I
would never want this to end but the
yeah I mean I don't know I mean it was
pretty much all the same all throughout
I mean the shows were great it was all
theaters the shows were great and then
you know going out especially the first
run that we did was really for because I
went on two runs but we went from I
don't know we went up into Canada we did
Toronto I think that's where we started
actually we did two nights in Toronto
then we went to Ottawa then we drove all
the way from Ottawa to Indianapolis
which is great on a bus cuz you just
sleep and then we did Indianapolis and
then st. Louis and that was a great run
because we went out every night and it
was fun it was a really really a blast
and then we did New Orleans Austin and
Dallas and we went out in New Orleans
and in Austin both pretty wild times I
think by the time we got to Dallas
everybody was pretty wore down so we
just hung out hey hot brethren and
sistren if you love comedy as much as we
do here at hot breath click the
subscribe button to join the hot breath
reverse and then watch more videos to
get even more comedy tips